godzilla vs kong
ape vs lizard it was supposed to be a
battle to the death
well at least a part of that was true
kong was left for dead
and we have done a video on why godzilla
didn't really kill kong
like he did with the other monsters in
the franchise demuros and ghidorah
but here in this video we shall go a bit
further and seek out the answers as to
why
kong went against history and his
instincts to save godzilla from mecca
godzilla
the big question about the team up that
brought the mechanized titan down
and how did gia know that the big g
wasn't a real enemy
but before we go there do remember to
hit that subscribe button to be a part
of the mind cue family
so now let's get down with this sickness
first of all
why did this fight happen in the first
place and was kong really the instigator
of the hong kong battle fast forwarding
a little bit through the movie to the
ocean battle scene
and godzilla's sparing kong and them
reaching the hollow earth
kong then discovers his species battle
axe which is powered by an old dorsal
plate
from one of godzilla's ancestors and the
axe hill
is made from a muter bone the axe is
powered up by the radiation from the
planet's center
by placing it in line with other tools
that are
in the godzilla shape in the ground it
is at this time that godzilla senses the
energy source and
instinctually fires his atomic breath
right down to the center of the earth
and that should have been that but kong
never lets go
with the ocean battle fresh on his mind
and the atomic breath creating
havoc on his ancestral home he
immediately went out to deal with
godzilla once and for all
so in the fight in hong kong godzilla
emerges as the definitive winner and
gong was left undead
but thankfully he was revived by the
heav that acted as a defibrillator
restarting gong's heart it is here that
the most peculiar thing happened
instead of gong going all out again on
godzilla he actually switched sides
with his rival to bring down the mecca
but why
common sense would have him helping
mechagodzilla instead
an enemy of an enemy is a friend as the
saying goes godzilla may be kong's
adversary but
he isn't really the villain in this
franchise godzilla is
if anything beyond our moral standards
behaving as a guardian of the earth
while still being adamant in his
supremacy over all other living
creatures
and when something threatens nature's
order godzilla does strike
so why did kong save godzilla
firstly kong would have realized that
after godzilla spared him by not giving
the killing
blow and disintegrating the big ape in
the end of the second battle
and they just rolled at each other and
godzilla just snuffs out and walked away
meaning that he was done with him and
wouldn't have even
balcon if not for the big ape coming up
from the hollow earth and literally
challenging him
kong would have then realized that
godzilla although not a friend
was not a mindless killer and he was in
the wrong for instigating the fight in
hong kong although godzilla did attack
the ancestral home
but to the big g's defense he simply
acted on instinct and fight to stop an
ancient itchy feeling
that led to the death of many of their
species on both sides
secondly when jia the only person nay
the only living being that gong places
his full trust on
tells the big ape that godzilla is not
the enemy he had to act accordingly in
order to prevent a bigger catastrophe
from happening
he also owed his new life to the humans
who revived him
and as a protector titan would have the
added responsibility of being
well a protector core might have not
acted in altruism to save the big g but
might have done so in order to prevent
mechagodzilla from killing
countless people in the likely scenario
that the big g is kill
kong isn't a dumb animal his intellect
would have been somewhat similar to
humans
if not surpassing us to him he would
have assessed the pros and cons of the
fight
that was currently happening and then
chose the right side
the team up to destroy the mecca
although nearly failing they both
did manage to combine their strengths in
order to rip the robot into pieces
and lastly kong when he was revived by
the heav
must have sent something wrong about the
situation
a second bio signal one that nearly
plunged the world into disarray during
the events of king of the monsters
although not seen in the movie king of
the monsters in the novelization it was
stated that kong did hear ghidorah's
call
and chose to ignore it and even went on
to kill the skull crawlers that tried to
join the others
so sensing this familiar ominous bio
signal
kong would have realized that if the
mecca succeeded then
there was no other way to stop it after
all it was
earth's protectors against an alien
unnatural being that had no place in the
natural order of things
so maybe one of these three reasons two
of them and maybe all three together
made kong go
on to save godzilla and destroy the
mecca
and yeah with that we come to the end of
the video on the three reasons as to why
kong saved godzilla
anyway click that like button for
support subscribe if you haven't to be a
part of the my q family
and smash that bell button for regular
updates on monsterverse and godzilla vs
kong videos
right here on minecube take care fam